>> As to the question of role models in the
Middle East, I'm far from an expert on the
Middle East, but I do know that in the US
having role models is extremely important.
When I went to college, the school I went
to had very few women on the faculty, there
were very few women in some of the classes
I took and it was a struggle to kind of figure
out how to, how to research, how to be a person
with a certain kind of role when there weren't
women there ahead of me. And I'm sure the
same kind of example will hold for other groups.
If you're, you look at a type of work and
you see no one there who's like you, not only
does it make it harder for you to get a job
buit it makes it harder for you to see yourself
in that position. So I think bringing together
people who have similar interests and encouraging
people to know other people who are doing
that kind of work or that kind of research
or that kind of thinking, but who are can
identify with can make a huge difference in
young people and people moving up in their
careers.